[Music]
if there are three things i love in this
world
it's a good friend a good joke and a
good walk
which is great because i can have all
three right here in the studio
tarek would you like to join me for a
long walk it'd be my pleasure
derek have you heard any good jokes
lately hmm
let me see oh have you uh heard the one
about steven tyler
no tell it well okay steven tyler the
lead singer of aerosmith
wanted to enjoy a nice evening with some
close friends so
he invited all his band mates over to
watch a movie
was the movie armageddon the movie was
armageddon
and believe it or not stephen tyler had
never seen it so
like everyone who has never seen
armageddon he was really looking forward
to it
he made a bunch of snacks bought a bunch
of pop did he order any pizza
he ordered tons of pizza so everybody
gets there
and they're having a great time they're
chatting they're hanging out they're
feeling good
was joe perry there joe perry had a
thing unfortunately couldn't make it
anyway after a little while stephen
tyler decides it's time to get the movie
started was it on blu-ray
it was on dvd so steven tyler pops the
movie in
sits on the couch and gets ready for the
ride of his life
but there's a problem everyone else is
still hanging out
there's a full-blown conversation going
on during the opening credits
was steven tyler starting to get
frustrated steven tyler was starting to
get frustrated
but being a gracious host he bit his
tongue and just turned the volume up a
little bit in the tv
was that enough it was not enough steven
tyler couldn't hear any dialogue
he was totally losing track of the plot
and yet the conversation just kept
getting louder and louder and louder
until finally
steven tyler couldn't take it anymore
what did he do
it's not what he did it's what he said
what did he say
he said guys i don't wanna miss a thing
and this has been a long walk
[Music]
you